yeah you gotta go crazy on twitch
because there's money especially if
you're [ __ ] with aiden ross
he's kind of like the um the drake of
twitch
or no what's the other guy's name ninja
no ninja the fortnite guy but but ninjas
ninja's rich
but ayden is the goat bro i hit like he
had a run that i ain't he had every
artist in his house
doing interviews on the game can we be
honest yeah it was very very
surprising to me that no one robbed him
because everything's cool
everyone was at his house and you know
entourages are there
hey it's just cool as hell bro i promise
you get around the air black down you're
cool as well how did you guys link up
because that was such a random thing to
see uh he dissed my people
like my dead homeboys but we talked
about it and i gotta understand it like
any mean no harm or not like that so
was it him uh like singing along to that
song he was singing along but he didn't
mean no harm he know what's going on but
he facetimed me we talked it up and then
i ended up coming to l.a
he would like pull up on me and i pulled
up to his house he had so many security
guards and all the type of [ __ ]
i ain't gonna do [ __ ] to you bro then we
did the online stream and we talked
about it is that kind of hard like um
when you know that like
there are people who sing along to that
record not knowing what the [ __ ] they're
singing along to
yeah
i don't know i'm tripping out hard to
just
i know you this is not your lifestyle so
i can understand you just vibing to them
you like most people don't think the way
you think yeah thank god you think that
way because most people are very
irrational when they're like
like you said like you know we were
talking earlier about the [ __ ] with the
with the baby and then be a young boy
it's like why are people so worked up
over this dude that he ain't got [ __ ] to
do without like this whole situation
like
but yeah and i think that's that's a
good thing man